[Music]
20-17 isn't just a Nintendo switches
launch year it's also the year we get
new mario kart fire emblem and Super
Mario games we've compiled a list of
confirmed 2017 switch exclusives for
your convenience and to stay up to date
with all of Nintendo's hottest titles
don't forget to Like and subscribe arms
takes the motion control boxing of Wii
Sports to the next level you can punch
dodge bob and weave as a colorful cast
of characters each with their own
special attacks and skills and if you
don't want to throw jabs with the joy
cons arm support standard controls as
well Fire Emblem warriors mixes the
Musso gameplay of dynasty warriors with
nintendo's premier tactics game we've
only seen fire emblem awakening scrum in
action so far but don't be surprised if
we see other fan favorites like I Marth
and lucina on the battlefield in the
future whether you miss the last mario
kart game on wii u or you just want to
speed back onto the track with more
characters and a new battle mode mario
kart 8 deluxe is for you we just got our
hands on the game at PAX East so check
out that off-screen gameplay to see the
new battle mode in action the Inklings
are returning this summer with splatoon
to the squid kids are armed with new
toys and some remixed versions of fan
favorite weapons from the first game and
with the switches portability you can
fight your goop covered turf wars from
just about anywhere Super Mario Odyssey
is pitched as a proper follow-up to
Super Mario 64 and super mario sunshine
and it shows the trailer gave us a look
at some truly massive worlds and we'll
get to explore all the city's jungles
and deserts with Mario's new googly eyed
hat companion if you want a tight 2d
fighting game you can't go wrong with
ultra street fighter to the final
challengers comes to switch with all the
characters you love plus a new
first-person mode that utilizes the joy
console ether hadoukens yourself finally
Xenoblade Chronicles 2 is the first
open-world JRPG for the switch this time
around a new cast of characters will
explore a massive world in search of
something called Elyse
ziam if you enjoy Xenoblade Chronicles X
on the Wii U chances are you'll be on
board with this too and those are all
the Nintendo switch exclusives slated
for this year and remember that plenty
more could be announced in the future
keep an eye on gamespot for all the
latest on all of those plus all the
reviews features and gameplay you could
ever need
[Music]
you